chine malheureusement d'elle demain tout
seul c'est vous passerez la
saint-valentin seule celle seul tel un
clip au salon de l'étudiant
je dis ça comme un jockey son cheval
ouais ah oui comme bataille sans
fontaine comme une couscous son poids
chiche
gilles tout le monde me demande pourquoi
gilles et fatou sont dans la tourmente à
cause d' isabelle goupil truc je préfère
des réchauds vous le savez gilles
isabelle se sont embrassés ouais
la langue est sorti le physique aussi et
de fil en aiguille pas tout est parti ça
arrive c'est sur des textes où sa motion
en fait des rimes en jeu vous dire toute
la vérité gilles nous avons appelé fatou
f à tous
fatou el fath et onu tout tout tout tout
fatou pour qu'elle vienne ce soir mais
fatou nous a dit non google hanouna non
c'est pas dit ça noms adresses vous
allez tu évolues plus courtois oui
absolument
elle vous a dit ta gueule comme ça non
non c'est pas le genre de fatwa non
donnera tout est une balance on est à
quelques jours d'écart à part donges et
huawei alors c'est son site d'astrologie
mais je sais que ce soir fatou regarde
elle nous regarde mathieu tu le sais mon
chef gilles je vous le dis j'ai pris ma
décision avec matthieu delormeau
elle est très bon d'installer un
téléphone sur ce plateau on va appeler
le fatou phone oui vous allez refaire
une déclaration d'amour à fatou j'allais
dire une dernière fois afin tout je
t'aime pour qu'elle revienne ne te pas
la dernière à temps aux racines chez
sera la dernière chance
siphat ou le désir elle pas plaint
n'importe quel moment le numéro de
l'émission elle le sait bien
fabien philippe votre maître le
téléphone dans l'udc c'est l'autre atout
phone elle sera branché il est branché
vous inquiétez pas bon chez le
directement sur votre métier et elle
apprécierait que man / mettre une
ceinture du sénégal russe électro cure
attrapa niveau téléphone pour qu'on
s'entend que si ce téléphone ne sonne
pas avant la fin d'émission
exactement gilles célibataire fatou si
tu étais ému par ce que va dire gilles
tu peux nous happe et ul numéro fatou
peut nous appeler n'importe quel membre
a pas on enlève la fin de l'émission
l'émission sera finie aux alentours de
23 heures
gilles c'est ta dernière chance fatouh
un numéro fatou est la seule au monde à
connaître ce numéro c'est à dire que si
ça sonne serré ça n'est pas quelqu'un
qui veut nous demander des choses non ce
n'est pas pilote ce n'est pas dominos
puis dire ça n'est pas speed rabbit
non c'est fatou va tout avec un grand f
comme flageolets à la jolie aux failles
aux quelque chose qui fait péter gill et
toussa toussa son compteur si les gens
savaient ça quelle leçon
gilles mon chéri
c'est j'ai envie de te dire la dernière
chance je voyage
fatou et toi c'est comme le bus vous
attendez souvent vous êtes très peu à
monter dedans toile pour toi non mais ça
veut dire qu'ils sont retrouve jamais ah
oui d'accord
semple a compris j'ai compris vous
n'êtes jamais alors même endroit au même
moment
ah oui oui il est mieux dit que personne
montre d'enfin double n'étaient pas tous
ces thèmes bah oui elle a pris la place
une tête de busquets fatou bâ tout est
magnifique
on rappelle que robuchon monde par
devant on s'empare d'un
quand on a plus rares et demandées
allez gilles mongil où elle est la fatwa
alors elle nous regarde pas tous nous
regarde oui à moins qu'elle avait menti
et des 'stress test' allemand jamais pas
tous ne ment jamais c'est une balance
comme moi vous mentez jamais non plus
beaucoup chéri
tieger je sais que j'ai fait une bêtise
j'arrête pas de penser à toi je me sens
tout seul je me sens tout nu je me sens
a abandonné je voudrais dire que c'est
la saint valentin et je sais que c'est
ma dernière chance du secteur du mas a
pardonné parce que j'étais profondément
je lisais ce matin et je t'ai blessé en
étant le seul responsable et son ou ses
coûts alors chéri voudrait bien en
appelant redonner une chance à notre
amour redonner un élan à notre histoire
j'ai fait une énorme bêtise je l'assumé
totalement je voudrais continuer à être
ton valentin sans toi y'a pas de vie
emplois selon lui c'est vite quoi série
je voudrais revenir demain de souhaiter
la saint-valentin t'embrasser prendre
dans mes bras te dire que voilà j'ai
fait une bêtise mais je t'aime
j'aurais aimé demain plus qu'aujourd'hui
je renoncerai jamais à cet amour tu es
la femme la plus merveilleuse du monde
j'ai pas été à la hauteur
je voudrais
[Applaudissements]
tu nous regardes pas tout tu es la seule
à avoir le numéro alors ne fait pas de
118 218 elle nous appelle nous et remet
gilles sur les bons rails car gilles
sans toi driver moi ça va lui aussi moi
je suis aussi un amateur ab à mes heures
perdues
oui oui c'est vrai oui c'était pas mal
non plus mais bien serge il assure qu'il
s'agit le direct et sincère comme
d'habitude le gilou on va attendre
a batu à la une heure et demie pour nous
appeler j'espère que fatou va nous
appeler si ce téléphone sonne
ce sera mathieu qui répondra aux là mais
c'est bon c'est vous savez répondent les
idées